flying puppy you're almost there just a
little further flying puppies dang it
Michael why didn't you think of that for
your neighborhood
[Music]
[Music]
oh did you're back
Jason yeah what but how why funny story
remember how I made you something and I
thought I lost it because it wasn't in
my pocket turns out it was in my other
pocket by the time I found it you were
gone I was just gonna leave it for you
but I was worried it would get eaten by
that magic squirrel so I decided to wait
for you to come back every so often a
different Janet came but
I knew it wasn't you Jason it's been
like a thousand berries I know but I
wanted to see you again it was actually
pretty easy to wait I sort of just sat
quietly and let my mind Drift Away
thought about you and the Infinity of
the universe
kind of like a monk what do you mean
um hi are you uh are you are you hypatia
of Alexandria yep how's it hanging this
is hanging really well
um I I gotta say I was expecting you to
be still you know ancient Greek oh well
we sort of stay current in this place
what are the big things from Earth
recently um the Industrial Revolution
Manhattan Project Gangnam Style I feel
like I get it it's really hard I could
just tell somehow it's my face
yes it is hi sorry I'm Eleanor this
exuberant weirdo is cheaty we're new in
town first question how do you get the
of in your name is it just like where
you hung out the most like m-i- Eleanor
of the Cheesecake Factory bar also is it
hypatia or hypatia or in the ancient
Greek who put Tia there's a lot of fun
debate about this you know what just
call me Patty
okay well uh Patty uh I'm a huge fan I I
had a post review on my wall in high
school well actually it was just a
poster of Trinity from The Matrix but
that's how I imagined you would look
because you're so cool oh is she the
reason you got beat up so much she's one
of them
I feel just like Dorothy when she lands
it off excited incredulous
much taller than everyone else around me
what's everyone want to do first racing
go-karts with monkeys sure is my
lifelong dream monkeys are the ideal
go-kart opponents they're funny enough
to give the finger but not smart enough
to win
does that mean me you're a good Janet
and we're in a good place I don't know
who else it would mean okay no pressure
I was born to do this not born
[Music]
okay so I now know all the information
about the good place in a nutshell it
slaps first thing to tell you humans
can't see the good place all at once or
their brains will be scrambled cool
maybe I'll finally get some of those
squigglies on my brain doctor said my
brains are smooth as they make you all
need to wait out here for a bit so you
can adjust when you're ready you will be
honored with a welcome Gala magically
planned by the good place based on your
personalities like the targeted
Instagram out of parties
you know I bought the coolest sunglasses
from one of those ads
whoa
it's like I'm inside the internet
okay could we just keep moving you look
a little pale did you get sick from the
hot air balloon I bet if you throw up
it'll just be butterflies or something
I'm fine I just um
I don't belong here there's no telling
what will happen to a demon who steps
Foot In This Place promise me if I'm
vaporized you guys just keep having fun
oh my goodness that chime is so soothing
feels like my brain is being massaged by
a baby deer oh boy what if that's some
sort of demon alarm to alert the cops
that I'm here you won't need all your
weed I don't have weed you know it took
me a while to figure it out but earlier
when you were walking back and forth
through the door it hit me you will
never be at peace until you get the one
thing you truly want
I'm
I'm gonna be a real boy Pinocchio the
judge gave me the power to make you an
actual human
goodbye fire squid hello silver fox
oh Eleanor oh my goodness now you need
to be sure about this you're gonna live
down there for like
some amount of time you'll die really
die then you'll enter an afterlife test
be judged on what you did the whole deal
at least so we think while you're down
there this entire system could be
changed Sean might launch a coup someone
could design a whole new system you
won't really know what's going to happen
to you
that's what makes it special I won't
exactly know what's going to happen
after I die
nothing more human than that
besides texting people that you're five
minutes away when you haven't even left
the house
[Music]
thank you Ellen
thank you
[Music]
you're very welcome
[Music]
hey Mike where you headed today Earth
actually oh
a while is the return quicker no need
one-way trip
wow
okay
good luck thank you
I have something for you yeah
[Music]
Rob it's it sure is
thank you
you know what
I got the perfect name for him
Mr jumpy legs
I thought you were gonna
never mind I
oh man I studied so much things art and
music and the um the one with the number
piles where I'd be like two and you'd be
like six Math yes and then I came here
where time stretched out forever and
every second of my existence was amazing
but my brain became this big dumb blob
so we finally make it into the good
place and now we're just gonna become
zombies
why haven't you told anyone about this
about what dude damn it
damn it we have to find the others right
now
but there's math on my shirt come on is
it an s or a map
have you seen Eleanor and chitty there's
something very wrong with this party and
it's not just that the caviar is being
served on top of the jello shots we are
the First new people here in 500 years
and no one seems to care I know even the
coach janits are kind of weird they're
like hi there
when I do it it's cool but when they do
it it's lame
fun great so little
everyone here is a happiness zombie and
no one is doing anything about it
because by the time they realize it's
happening everyone is too far gone to
care
oh hello I'm tahani hi I'm milkshake do
you want a milkshake okay we need to
tell someone before we're too zonked out
to remember why we're here we need to
find the committee the committee is me I
am committee it me what they tricked me
and put me in charge of the good place
and then literally ran away and then
what happened the Sorting Hat put you in
Hufflepuff rusted come on I know we have
problems you can't expect me to ignore
this we're in Paradise surely some
people here are enjoying themselves hey
guys I'm back go karting but monkeys got
boring really fast you did oh
foreign